it's unusual at that time freshmen
haven't carried a team like that
nowadays it's not unusual but at that
time they have two freshmen carrier
teams the national championship was
special
first school dad was recruiting me with
sandwiches
Carmela Anthony I went to see when he
was a junior I rarely go out during the
year but my assistant Troy Weaver and I
said you know coach you gotta come see
this kid I was about to go to that leg
directly like we need a private plane
cuz we need the kid to come down to see
this game once I saw Bay I've come to
Baltimore came to my neighborhood like I
just felt like it was a real news there
like I felt like I told him something
throughout the course of the day in
school is like old Sarah chooses coming
to the game Bahamas coming to the game
so I'm like oh it's a nice a nice well
the game starts and he comes down he
hits a three then he went by that guy
and pulled up and hit about a 15 footer
then he came back and he stole the ball
he went down and dumped on two guys and
I turned to Troy as my assistant I said
why weren't we down here before this
yeah he looked at me like he got me
seeing all these other guys it's the
best play in the country so he had said
to me this guy could help us win a
national championship I said I think you
might be right you know he's he's that
good
turned out to be a good one of my few
good predictions the first time I had
met Melo was at ABCD camp I just watched
him play against let me cook who was who
was a you know probably know by most
recruiting analysts and number one
player in the country and I watched Melo
do what he does and I was immediately
blown away we knew with Jerry and
Carmelo coming in we had two great
freshmen I remember how well he was
shooting the basketball and on my whole
thing this is the guy that's going to
Sanford she was like there's a little
short white guy going - sorry - this is
gonna be my point guard the first time
playing pickup over on campus as a group
at Syracuse I remember calling my father
and said the real deal he's the real
deal
we really win the tournament and we
barely beat Manhattan a good man had to
and then we played Oklahoma State we're
down 16 first half going it's a halftime
Bingham and there he's don't his
civilities yelling and breaking
chalkboards and TVs and we came out and
we won that game then from there like
our confidence is cruel
[Applause]
[Music]
we dream about this today one weakness
and out front we can do it
we took this dance to the Final Four we
wanted to the Final Four thinking if
we're gonna win this this is this is our
Thompson
[Applause]
they had the Defensive Player of the
Year playing him with Carmelo he just
was unstoppable and we needed every bit
of it
[Applause]
teamwork makes an unbelievable play
along the baseline off a loose ball
[Applause]
not gonna mention what the junk is
referred to Row IV I talked I talked
rational on all day about that when we
first traded for mellow that was the
first thing he pointed out like skinny
guy to once he got that dumb people that
we took their soul and took their heart
like you felt it you filled it leave
that dump kind of took us to a whole
another level at that game
after the Texas game I didn't sleep that
night the next day that Sunday I'm in
walking outside on Bourbon Street just
seeing everything just taking it all in
and go back and can't sleep the night
before the national championship game
and wake up in the morning no pregame
nap I was just at an all-time high
I've never been that excited before but
at ease to even not his sleep hours
let's get this game going they saw
before
really excited
he wasn't in any way nervous which you
don't expect that from a freshman you
know behind at that point in time he was
you know national championship he'd been
there before she's smart at this side he
was pacing around and he just wasn't
himself and I went up to him I like
coach don't worry we got this we don't
get this done
Carmelo had told me before the game not
to worry he had that we him we had he
said we've got it
[Applause]
he came to me before the game it was
like I feel it tonight that's all he
said I feel it's not he hit the first
one from deep then he had another one
deep and he looked at in his life I told
you then they went zone and when they
wouldn't zone my eyes lit up because I
know I could stretch the defense
across him shopping half-court some like
what you shooting that for that's too
far that was the feel good shot
that was the I made a few and bam is
always there you don't shoot that now
should thank you know in a bay hounds
voice and then when he make any black
yeah good job
Jerry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
goes out
fine forget sit fighter puts up the shot
[Applause]
it's the only time in my life that I ran
aimlessly I didn't know where I was
going and they're just pure elation and
I remember Melo being on the bottom of
that pile and it wasn't it wasn't him
celebrating with him and agonizing pain
because so many guys are on top of him
I'm never saying before the game so I
said if we win like I do not want to be
on the bottom of the Power understand if
we all you know we all laughing it just
so happened I'm gonna bottom of the pond
but like that moment I could see why
Jerry Lawler was chasing them but that's
the best feeling that they don't come
around coach was so close a few times
and there's so many great players that
that was as rewarding as anything was
was to win it for coach when you're not
ranked preseason and you can get to the
Final Four
would have been a heck of the year but
to win it to see them celebrate was what
was great we never believed that we had
a shot so Foster come in as freshmen so
winning it all like Denman's Allah I
think that made that year
a little bit more special
you